an overview of the state of the pandemic
and on new practices that will help keep
schools open
and dr fauci will provide an update on
the latest science and the importance of
boosters
but before we start
i want to talk about how we should think
about this moment
as we've explained in prior briefings
the omicron variant is more
transmissible
and our medical experts anticipate it
will lead to a rise in cases
but unlike last winter we now have the
power to protect ourselves
our vaccines work against omicron
especially for people who get booster
shots when they are eligible
if you are vaccinated you could test
positive
but if you do get covered your case will
likely be asymptomatic
or mild
we are intent on not letting omicron
disrupt work in school for the
vaccinated
you've done the right thing and we will
get through this
for the unvaccinated
you're looking at a winter of severe
illness and death
for yourselves your families
and the hospitals you may soon overwhelm
so our message to every american is
clear
there is action you can take to protect
yourself and your family
wear a mask in public indoor settings
get vaccinated
get your kids vaccinated
and get a booster shot when you're
eligible
we are prepared to confront this new
challenge
we have plenty of vaccines and booster
shots available at convenient locations
and for no cost
there's clear guidance on masking to
help slow the spread
and we have emergency medical teams to
respond to surges as necessary
so this is not a moment to panic
because we know how to protect people
and we have the tools to do
it but we need the american people to do
their part
to protect themselves
their children and their communities
the more people get vaccinated the less
severe this omicron outbreak will be
160 000 unvaccinated people have already
needlessly lost their lives
just since june
and this number will continue to go up
until the unvaccinated take action
so i'll say it once more
get vaccinated
with that i'll turn it over to dr
wolinski
thank you jack and good morning everyone
i'd like to start by walking you through
today's data the current seven day daily
average of cases is at about 119
500 per day the seven day average of
hospital admissions is at about 7 800
per day an increase of about four
percent over the prior week and the
seven-day average of daily deaths is at
about 1200 per day which is at an
increase of over eight percent from the
prior week
now let me bring you up to date on what
we know about omicron
at least 39 states and over 75 countries
have reported confirmed cases of the
omicron variant and although delta
continues to circulate widely in the
united states omicron is increasing
rapidly and we expect it to become the
dominant strain in the united states as
it has in other countries in the coming
weeks
we've seen cases of omicron among those
who are both vaccinated and boosted and
we believe these cases are milder or
asymptomatic because of vaccine
protection
what we do know is we have the tools to
protect ourselves against cova-19 we
have vaccines we have boosters and we
know multi-layer prevention strategies
masks in public indoor settings
practicing physical distancing frequent
hand washing improving ventilation and
testing to slow transmission are vitally
important especially as we prepare for
more omicron and even if you are
vaccinated and boosted
this morning i want to talk with you now
about how we can use these tools to help
keep our children in school
over the past few months cdc has
collaborated with school districts
across the country to evaluate a new
strategy known as test to stay
today we're releasing cdc science on
tests to stay that allows unvaccinated
children to stay in school even if they
have been exposed to the virus so that
they don't have to miss school while
they're quarantining at home
in the test to stay protocol there's
increased testing of close contacts
after a covet 19 exposure and that
testing needs to be at least twice
during the seven day period after
exposure
if exposed children meet a certain
criteria and continue to test negative
they can stay in school instead of
quarantining at home cdc is releasing
two mmwr reports with evidence
supporting the use of tests to stay and
how well it worked in two communities
lake county illinois and los angeles
county
these studies demonstrate the test to
stay works to keep unvaccinated children
in school safely
in order for tests to stay to be
implemented safely and correctly some
key prevention measures need to be
included
in both studies masks were worn
consistently and correctly
close contacts of a positive case were
monitored for symptoms and stayed home
if they became ill and those who did not
develop symptoms had regular testing
test to stay as an encouraging public
health practice to keep our children in
school and cdc is updating our materials
to help schools and parents know how to
best implement this promising and now
proven practice along with our
multi-layered prevention strategies that
will help keep our children in the
classroom safely
importantly vaccination is another
critical piece and our multi-layer
prevention strategies to protect our
children from coverbank team i'd like to
take another moment to encourage parents
to get their children vaccinated
just yesterday cdc's advisory committee
on immunization practices met to discuss
new safety data following six weeks of
covet 19 vaccinations in children
between the ages of 5 to 11.
we now have experience vaccinating over
20 million children under the age of 17
and over 5 million of whom are under the
age of 11.
looking specifically at vaccine safety
data from over 50 000 children 5 to 11
years old we found no evidence of
serious safety concerns
the most common reported side effect
including pain included pain at the
injection site fever tiredness and
headaches muscle aches which we know are
normal and are all signs of the body
that the body is building immunity to
the virus
this further adds to the strong evidence
of the safety of these vaccines for
children and should be an encouraging
reason for those who are waiting for
more data to now feel confident in
making the decision to get your child
vaccinated
in addition to reviewing safety data
yesterday cdc's advisory committee on
vaccine experts met to evaluate
recommendations surrounding the johnson
johnson cova 19 vaccine evaluating the
benefits of vaccination the safety data
and rare adverse events and the coven 19
vaccine supply
following their discussion acip made a
recommendation to preferentially use
mrna vaccines over the johnson and
johnson vaccine and i endorsed their
recommendation and agreed with the
advisory committee's emphasis
importantly that given the current state
of the pandemic both here and around the
world
any vaccination is better than no
vaccination
individuals who are unable or unwilling
to receive an mrna vaccine will continue
to have access to johnson and johnson
cova 19 vaccines
and finally as we head into the holiday
season when many will be gathering with
their loved ones i want to again
encourage everyone to utilize the proven
prevention strategies that keep everyone
safe get vaccinated and get boosted
mask in public indoor settings physical
distancing hand washing
improved ventilation and testing to slow
transmission we know that these
strategies work and will help to keep
you and your loved ones safe and healthy
this holiday season
thank you i'll now turn things over to
dr fauci
thank you very much dr wolinski i'd like
to spend the next couple of minutes uh
talking about the importance
of covert 19 booster shots both in the
current delta surge and in the
inevitable upcoming omicron surge so if
i could have the next slide let's take a
look at some of the data that fortifies
what i just said
this is a recently published study in
the new england journal
looking at individuals 50 years of age
or over who received the booster about
five months after a second dose of the
fisa bioentec
there was a 90 percent lower mortality
due to covert 19 than participants who
did not receive a boost now albeit the
mortality is low in people who are
vaccinated anyway however it goes down
to practically negligible values if you
look at the blue line compared to the
pink line next slide now let's take a
look at omicron specific situations
in this study
one looked at three separate vaccines
the mrna of morberna the pfizer and then
the ad 26
j and j followed by an mrna boost again
if you look
at the
times two which means a standard
vaccination
and then take a look at the pseudo-virus
neutralization
following the boost
the increment of that is really rather
profound 19 times for the one on the
left
27 times for the one in the middle and
four times for the one on the right next
slide
now also if you look at the
neutralization of multiple different
variants by pseudovirus analysis
and take a look again at two separate
studies
one from the vaccine research center at
nih and one from duke university
note on the left panels
four weeks following the second dose
look specifically at the pink bar
there you see a rather low
level of neutralization with omicron
however if you look at two weeks post
the third or booster dose
note how much it goes up for example if
you look at the omicron comparing in the
duke line you see it is about 2002
whereas after a second dose it's only
62. a dramatic increase next slide
another example if you look at the
sensitivity of variance to
neutralization by people who were
vaccinated with the fisa vaccine
if you look again five months after the
second dose and look under omicron the
red circles
nominal in other words virtually no
degree of neutralization protection
again
one month after the third dose it goes
well within the protective range next
slide
if you look at now convalescent syrup
and take a look at each of the panels
on the left you have a convalescent
serum six months after infection
again the level of protection that would
be projected from the antibody levels is
very low as you see with omicron very
low level
these circles that are red 12 months
later it even gets worse
but take a look at what happens if you
take a person who's convalescent
but you boost that person now with a
dose of pfizer and wait one month
the red circles go way up into the
protective range next slide and then if
you look at actual clinical issues take
a look in a uk study
about individuals who had ace who had
symptomatic infection
look at delta in the blue boxes
as you go the time since the vaccine
and look at the weeks which i showed on
the bottom line you get a diminution
against delta but a very profound
diminution below 40
effectiveness with delta when you boost
not only do you bring it up to delta in
the blue but also to omicron what does
all of this tell us last slide
we are in the mid in a situation we are
now facing a very important delta surge
and we are looking over our shoulder at
an oncoming omicron surge
clearly unvaccinated individuals as jeff
said in the beginning are really at a
high risk of serious involvement
including hospitalization
the fully vaccinated are doing much
better off but as i've shown you in the
previous five or six slide the optimum
protection is fully vaccinated plus a
boost so the bottom line of what we've
been telling you all along it is
critical to get vaccinated if you are
vaccinated as critical for optimal
protection to get boosted
back to you jeff
well thank you doctors with that let's
open it up for some questions over to
you kevin
thanks jeff uh let's go back to serena
marshall from now this
thank you i appreciate you doing this
and coming back to me right away so i
just wanted to for some clarity here are
we seeing delta
we're seeing it be more infectious but
is there evidence with the breakthrough
infections that they're more severe in
any way um is there any evidence to that
you could talk about with long covid
we've seen some new data that roughly 30
to 40 percent of anyone who tests
positive have resulted in long covid as
well and uh there's a lot of unknowns
when it comes to how that's going to
play out
now we start with you dr fauci
well i think you meant to say omicron
yes omicron is more
uh transmissible everything we know
about it from what we're seeing not only
in south africa but its distribution
throughout the world and as well as in
our own country
we see what's going on in new york city
when we're getting beyond double digits
of omicron being the primary variant
there in that percentage with regard to
the seriousness of infection uh really
it's still up in the air right now
because there are a lot of confounding
issues as to whether or not it is less
severe
certainly looking at what we see it does
not look like it is more severe but we
have to hold with and withhold judgment
about to the uh
severity being less
with regard to long covert we don't have
as enough information on omicron with
regard to long covert i would not expect
it's going to be any different than we
have with delta but we'll have to wait
to see until we get more experience
next question please
let's go to cheyenne haslett at abc news
thanks guys um my first question uh for
dr fauci you showed data showing how
little protection people have after two
doses a few months after getting it so
should americans who are not eligible
for their booster yet not six months
past their last shot be concerned that
they're not well protected against
omicron and get boosted sooner than six
months
and then my second question on our
booster rate still being very low only
30 of the fully vaccinated how
concerning is that as we head into this
larger surge
well let me answer the second one first
and that is the concern i mean obviously
that's the reason why
i have spent
essentially my entire brief presentation
on urging people to get boosted for the
simple reason that we do get optimal
protection from a boost you mentioned
the lowering of protection and if you
look at some of the slides i showed a
quote fully vaccinated person after a
period of time
clearly has a diminution you still get
protection that's reasonably good
against hospitalization
we want to make that better with the
booster whether or not we're going to
change
what the time interval between your last
vaccination and your boost we always
have these on the table for discussion
but right now there's not been a
decision on that
the right way to think about um the
percent boosted is those eligible and
we've uh now boosted about 60 million
americans
that's about 40 percent for zero percent
of the eligible americans importantly
of those over 65 we're now more than 60
percent
and that's important because they are
the most vulnerable
we are boosting about a million uh
people a day so booster shots are
running at a million per day
and that is accelerated from where we
were um as dr fauci said uh stressing
the importance of getting the boost when
people are eligible and the president's
winter plan really builds uh momentum
here pharmacies are expanding
appointments and hours and walk-in
availability we're launching as you know
family vaccination sites where
parents can get boosted at the same time
that their five to 11 year old might get
their first or second shot
medicare is reaching out to
tens of millions of seniors encouraging
them to get roosters so our message is
very clear clinically the docs have said
as soon as you're eligible for a booster
get a booster we have plenty of supply
we now have ninety thousand sites up
another ten thousand from a few weeks
ago ninety 000 sites that are convenient
and as you know getting a booster shot
is free and everyone should get their
booster shot as soon as possible
next question
let's go to elizabeth wise at usa today
elizabeth
sorry can you hear me now
oh sorry about that okay uh this would
be a question for dr walensky
uh in light of omicron's higher
transmissibility rate potentially
including people who are vaccinated is
the cdc reconsidering its
recommendations that vaccinated people
don't need to self-isolate after an
exposure to someone who has coveted
uh thank you for that question we are
actively following the science in that
area with regard to um how the viral
burden is both among vaccinated people
and unvaccinated people and the natural
history of that viral burden with regard
to
isolation and as that science emerges we
will update our evidence if need be
next question
let's go to ouija jing at cbs news
thank you kevin um first i have a
question for dr falchi
i wonder if omicron is more
transmissible just because
the nature of the variant or because the
booster and vaccine offer less
protection against contracting omicron
compared to other variants or a mix of
both
and for dr walensky given your new
recommendation for students to test to
stay does that extend to adults who are
exposed to
that a 14-day quarantine is no longer
necessary as long as you test negative
and when you say continue to test
negative how often should kids be
getting tested to stay in school after
exposure thanks
well with regard to the first question
if you look at the configuration and the
constellation
of amino acid substitutions which result
from mutations on the spike proteins you
would have predicted that this would be
a more transmissible virus because of
its ability to bind to the receptors on
the cells so you need only look at the
virus itself to determine why it is more
transmissible what it actually is
yeah with regard to tests to say so this
was a strategy that looked at
unvaccinated children because vaccines
were not available of course in our
school setting we would encourage that
all of our teachers who would be
eligible both be vaccinated as well as
boosted
with regard to the protocols there are
numerous jurisdictions that are looking
at test to stay strategies some of them
are we're testing every day some of them
every other day and some of them twice a
week so we would say no less frequent
than twice a week in order to employ the
tests to stay protocols and these were
limited to schools to be clear so we
don't yet have evidence about test to
stay protocols in other settings
kevin
next question
let's go to last question sabrina
siddiqui at the wall street journal
thank you so much um
uh just two good questions uh france has
imposed travel restrictions on the uk
and several other eu countries
strengthening their border controls
uh are you reconsidering travel from
either the uk or the eu given the covet
outbreaks there and then secondly i know
we're in a very different place with
vaccines and boosters than we were last
year but how would you characterize your
message to the american people going
into the holidays is it safe for
families and friends to get together
before christmas and what is your
message to people as we approach the
holiday season
so why don't i take the first question
and then i'll hand it over to dr
wolinski about the holiday season
let me start with the fact that
the u.s has strict protocols in place to
help protect the american people
and stop the spread of the disease
as it relates to international travel
foreign nationals all four nationals
coming into the u.s
from a part of the world where the
travel is not restricted
due to omicron must be fully vaccinated
and show proof of a negative test
and we've tightened that deadline or
that time frame for the negative test to
be within one day of boarding a flight
the cdc also strongly recommends that
everyone get tested uh three to five
days after they arrive in the u.s
but as we've done throughout the
pandemic we will continue to follow the
science and evaluate the best protocols
for international travel and we'll keep
people up to date most importantly the
american people safe
dr wilinski
yeah as you know sabrina i think we're
in a very different place this year than
we were last year and we really do want
people to be able to gather and gather
safely we have the tools now to do it
and what we're really saying is please
rely on those tools get vaccinated if
you're eligible for a boost get boosted
and importantly a week before the
holidays
indoor mask in these areas that have 90
percent of our counties have a
substantial or high transmission use the
next week to make sure you're practicing
those safe prevention mitigation
strategies so that when you come
together for the holidays that people
have been not exposed to the virus
because in fact they've been vaccinated
boosted and masked and for that extra
reassurance as we have more disease in
this country right now do a test and
make sure that you're negative before
you mix and gather in different
households
okay well thank you we look forward to
speaking next week but i hope everybody
has a safe uh and relaxing weekend thank
you
you